Meechum arid was a bright and
accomplished young woman her friends say
she paid for her bravery with her life
this is the first time we've heard from
a survivor of meat Raziel fated boat
Ahmed Nadi also from Iran has revealed
how Mitra dived into the sea to reach a
rescue rope from another boat as their
ding he began to sink in the English
Channel mr. hat meter hey tell her she
can't be as we are we are building a
more scalable wooden energy applications
Oh My GD taught me that commence the
cost that's the smaller wood to give
back to get this ticket she called by
name - Augusta UK Coast Guard's rescued
19 people from the ill-fated dinghy in
August Iranians and Iraqis including a
one-year-old child and a five month old
baby
Ahmed says Mitra jumped into the water
saying she was able to swim with Corey
Katya
Mike and Matt with the mattress team
upon him mom the hotel room betcha
Mitra had a PhD and studied psychology
and science in Thailand she wanted to
get to England to be with her boyfriend
he's now apparently gone into hiding
fearful of the smugglers can you show me
the photograph of nature when Mitra
disappeared her family in Iran sent
survivors from the boat a photograph of
their daughter trying to establish for
certain whether or not she had been on
board we spoke to meet hrus father
Mohammed II in Iran he had no idea
police on both sides of the channel were
questioning four people
Metra's body is believed to have been
washed up on the Dutch coast
it's thought she is the first person we
know of who's died in the channel proof
if it were needed of just how dangerous
the illegal crossing is Lisa Holland Sky
News